a new seven-day ceasefire has come into
effect in Sudan but that hasn't stopped
the fighting between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces the
United Nations is calling for security
guarantees at the highest level to
ensure the safe passage of Aid convoys
Victoria gaytonby reports
intense fighting in hartum North despite
a seven-day ceasefire
[Music]
elsewhere in the capital a militarized
police unit exchanges fire with the
rapid support forces the Army led by
General Abdel fatah al-burhan has ruled
out negotiations
the government of Sudan has agreed only
to the ceasefire and not to any
mediation regarding the resolution of
the conflict this is simply because it
is a rebellion against the Sudanese
Armed Forces by a group once Affiliated
to the Army towards the final solution
will be decided on the ground
neighboring South Sudan brokered the
current ceasefire the latest in a string
of truces it wants the warring generals
to hold direct talks our approach and
strategy is to leave the solution to the
Sudanese people we cannot set
preconditions but we can facilitate the
meeting between the commanders of the
Army and the rapid support forces
the United Nations is using the
ceasefire to call for the safe passage
of desperately needed Aid humanitarian
Chief Martin Griffiths who's in Port
Sudan spoke to the leader of the rapid
support forces on Wednesday
after the call General Muhammad hamdan
daglow said he was committed to the
humanitarian truce safe passage of
people who want to leave and the
protection of Aid workers
Sudan is rich in natural resources such
as minerals and oil but despite this the
UN classifies it as a low-income country
and says it cannot cope with the
unfolding humanitarian crisis the
fighting needs to stop
and to stop now
before more people die and this conflict
explodes into an all-out war that could
affect the region for years to come the
fate of millions of sydneys is in the
hands of two men locked in a power
struggle refusing to lay down their
weapons and negotiate Victoria Gayton B
Al Jazeera we'll get an update with
Heber Morgan who's joining us from heart
swim so how about we keep hearing about
clashes in different parts of the
capital and the cities around it can you
give us a sense of who's actually making
gains on the ground
foreign
have made slides gains and both have
suffered setbacks when you look at the
Sudanese Army for example in the
northern part of the capital in the city
of Bahari specifically there was Heavy
rsf presence going all the way from hunt
Fire Bridge up until the banks of the
River Nile that is no longer the case
intense fighting has been ongoing for
the past few days in the city of bahri
in the northern part of the capital and
that's because it overlooks the
presidential Palace something that the
Sudanese Army has been trying to take
since the start of the fighting three
weeks ago and which is still under the
control of the rapid support forces so
the Sudanese Army has been focusing on
attacking the rsf positions in the
Northern parts of the capital with
intense airstrikes plumes of smoke have
been coming out of Bahari for the past
few days and Rapid support forces being
pushed further north east of the of the
capital where there are also airstrikes
being launched but the presidential
Palace which is a key facility that's
the Sudanese Army has been trying to
regain is still under the control of the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army has been launching attacks both
airstrikes and artillery attacks in
which the rapid support forces have been
repelling back so both sides trying to
maintain their positions at the same
time trying to make gains as the
ceasefire which is now the seventh
ceasefire doesn't appear to be holding
on the ground so how are people then
coping with the ongoing fighting and I
mean the so-called ceasefire doesn't
help them at all and and having them go
out and try to secure the basic
necessities
well people are trying to leave the
capital where they can and if they can
and if they have the financial means to
do so those who are trapped in the
Northern parts of the capital for
example have to cross a bridge to the
western part of the capital to the city
of Underman where there is fighting
ongoing but not as intense as the one in
the northern part and try to get their
groceries from there and then return
home but there are thousands of
thousands of people who are trapped in
their homes with no access to running
water or power since the fighting
started 20 days ago many of them saying
that the situation is quite dire and
it's even worse for those who are in
need of medical attention so dance
doctors union says that 12 000 people
are at risk of dying from
life-threatening diseases because
facilities like renal dialysis centers
heart treatment centers and Cancer
Treatment Centers have all been affected
by the fighting so people say that the
situation is continuing to deteriorate
day by day and they're waiting for a
ceasefire to hold for them to be able to
get access to hospitals or to their
basic necessities like food and water
thank you so much Morgan reporting from
Khartoum
well safaricir is a Sudanese and a
resident here in Qatar and she was in
Khartoum with her family when the
fighting started she joined us in the
studio earlier and she describes their
Journey out of the city
and in the root we saw
we saw so much conflict we saw
dead bodies we saw
people that were lost
carrying everything that they owned on
on a rucksack
and we saw Armed Forces
I learned things I never thought I
should learn I learned that you should
put up mattresses by the window
to soften the blow of a bomb so when the
glass shakes it doesn't hurt you
I learned the different sounds
of machinery
I learned the sounds of what fighter
jets sound like and the timing it takes
for a bomb to drop
I would count all of these things as I
would lay on the floor
just praying that a stray bullet didn't
hit our window
um
we did run out of water at one point
because electricity was cut water was
one of the water pipes got shot by stray
bullet and I made the decision with my
cousin to go grab water from a nearby
store that was still opening providing
Services through the back door and we
were shot out
it was incredibly risky to even
step outside your door